والتاريخي القائم في الاقصى
واحترام الوصاية الاردنية على
منعت شرطة الكيان الاسرائيلي
السفير الاردني لدى تل ابيب من
وبالتحديد في حلبة صراع السيارات
الكهربائية اذ اعلن ايلون ماسك
السكان في العام الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين لطالما كانت الدولة
الضيقة? لن تنتهي المفاجأة هنا
في كوكب الصين. مفاجأة جديدة
والطلب مما ادى الى تعزيز النمو
في الصين والعالم لكن هذا
يفتح المجال امام الهند لتصبح
دولة في العالم من حيث عدد
اكبر عدد من السكان لدولة في
العالم لكن وعلى غير العادة سجل
وواحد وستين اي منذ نحو ستين
عاما. وذلك حسب ما اعلن المكتب
الا في جانب واحد فهي تتراجع
فيه. نعم. الصينيون هم اصحاب
باتريوت. ولا زلنا في الولايات
المتحدة. حيث اعتبر التعلب
براجمات الصواريخ في اكثر من
جبهة شرقية وجنوبي البلاد. بينما
انها نفذت خلال اليوم الماضي
اكثر من خمسة وتسعين هجوما
الوطني للاحصاء في بكين. ليقول
المختصون ان هذا التراجع يعتبر
التي طالما سعت اليها كييف. بعد
ان كان كيسنجر من اتباع الواقعية
عن تخفيض وبنسبة عشرين في المئة
على اسعار السيارات الكهربائية
نتيجة ملائمة. الصين تعود خطوة
للوراء. الصين تتقدم في كل شيء
الامريكي وزير الخارجية الاسبق
لكاسنجر ان الهجوم الروسي على
يعيش هؤلاء الشياطين لنفنى نحن
الى الجنة وهم الى النار. ما هذا
النوويتين رحلة مجدولة استمرت
لاكثر من عشر ساعات فوق المياه
للقوات الاوكرانية. وها هي روسيا
تجري الاحماء لترد على الغربيين.
وصل مئة اوكراني الى الولايات
المتحدة للتدرب على نظام
الذي تقوله يا هذا? هل حانت
النهاية? ومن حروب التهديدات
والتصريحات نعود للحرب ذاتها.
حيث قالت هيئة الاركان
الاوكرانية ان قواتها شنت ست
عشرة غارة على مواقع تمركز
يمكننا الضغط على الزر النووي.
والسلام عليكم. وعلى الدنيا
السلام يا هذا. فما من بقاء
العالم ان فنت روسيا لا نريد ان
لتحديد كمية ونوع السلاح الذي
سترسله كل دولة وبشكل سريع. حيث
تتوجه كل من فرنسا والمانيا
وبريطانيا وبولندا لدعم قوي
الامريكيين من مواكبة العمليات
القتالية الاوكرانية فهل هذا هو
الاسرائيلي في هذه الحرب لتؤكد
صحيفة لوفيغاغو الفرنسية ان
جديد. واشار الصحيفة الى ان
القادة الاوروبيين سيجتمعون
ثقيلة من صناعة غربية لاول مرة
الى خط الجبهة خوفا من هجوم روسي
الغرب رفع المحظور عن اوكرانيا
وبدأ الاستعداد لارسال اسلحة
هي حرب كونية ولا تحتاج الا
لضغطة زر واحد. وفي الغالب ستكون
الى الاراضي الفلسطينية والى
المسجد الاقصى لينقل عنهم مدير
تايمز. واضافت الصحيفة ان ذلك
جاء بسبب عدم تمكن صانعي الاسلحة
السبب الحقيقي ام ان واشنطن تريد
توريط كوريا الجنوبية والكيان
دخول المسجد الاقصى وصل وفد من
سفراء وقناصل الاتحاد الاوروبي
عليه في العقد السابق وذلك بسبب
خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد
ارتفاع عدد البريطانيين الراغبين
بالتخلي عن جنسيتهم الى ثلاثين
حاجة اوكرانيا الماسة لقذائف
المدفعية بحسب صحيفة النيويورك
ذخائر لاوكرانيا من مخزونات في
اسرائيل وكوريا الجنوبية لتلبية
مهلا فالدعم لم ينته بعد. وهنا
دعم بالوكالة البنتاجون يرسل
الرئيس المصري والعاهل الاردني
في الامارات. شاووش اوغلو قرار
في الاقتصاد حسب التقارير فما
الذي سيفعله اصحاب العيون
تحولا تاريخيا. ومن المتوقع ان
يكون بداية فترة طويلة من
الاوقاف الاسلامية في القدس.
قلناها ونكررها. الحرب النووية
موسكو هي من تضغط على ذلك الزر.
فهل يتجاهل الغرب كل التحذيرات
عام اوقاف القدس تأكيدهم على
ضرورة الحفاظ على الوضع
وعشرين بضخ قدرات اضافية من
الغاز الى السوق العالمي. بعد ان
اعلنت رئيسة المفوضية الاوروبية
ان الاتحاد سيقدم دعما لاوكرانيا
لتعزيز نظام الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني. مهلا اهلا اهلا.
هذه الحرب ستكون نووية وليست
بالبندقية. هناك اكد رئيس
الهولندي مارك روتا والذي قال ان
بلاده قررت انفاق مليارين ونصف
مؤكدا استمرار بلاده في دعم
اوكرانيا ماليا وعسكريا. الدعم
لتوانيا انهم مستعدون لوقف
اعتمادهم على روسيا في مجال
لاوكرانيا. واضاف ان بلاده تنوي
الانضمام الى برنامج باتريوت
التاريخ لن ينسى انه في جميع
الحروب العالمية والدولية كانت
ها هو يغير رأيه ويقول ان انضمام
اوكرانيا الى حلف الناتو سيكون
شمال الاطلسي رغم انه كان في
السابق من المعارضين لهذه الخطوة
عدد سكان الصين تراجعا للمرة
الاولى منذ عام الف وتسعمائة
اوكرانيا اظهر انه لم يعد هناك
من مبرر لبقاء كييف خارج حلف
في المئة عن عام الفين وعشرين
ليصل العدد الى ستة اضعاف ما كان
الاوروبي. وزير الخارجية القطري.
سنكون جاهزين في الفين وسبعة
السويد عدم محاكمة متظاهرين
يروجون للارهاب سخيف للغاية.
الخطوة. الاحداث والتطورات. قمة
لقادة دول مجلس التعاون وبحضور
الامريكية ونقصد هنا شركة تسلا
فكيف ستنافس الصين مع هذه
سير المهمات القتالية في
الاتجاهات الرئيسية. خلال ذلك
المحايدة للمحيط المتجمد
الشمالي. ياتي الرد الروسي على
لسان الرئيس الشيشاني قديروف
والذي قال ان روسيا دولة نووية
جديدة في المسألة الاوكرانية.
مشيرا الى ان ما يحدث في
تصل الى وضع يسهل على الانخراط
ببساطة في عملية التفاوض. ليدخل
اوكرانيا هو نتيجة للاعداد
الامريكي لحرب هجينة ضد روسيا.
ويجب محاسبة روسيا على جرائمها
بحسب فيالى سخاءكم يا هؤلاء. لكن
التراجع يكثر فيه كبار السن ويقل
المواليد والشباب. ليصاحبه تراجع
الاكثر اكتظاظا بالسكان في
العالم مصدرا مهما للعمالة
الانخفاض في اعداد المواطنين
الصينيين. كما انه حسب قولهم
منه. مضيفا ان واشنطن تستخدم
اسلوب هتلر لتدمير روسيا. كما
ليرد عليه وزير الخارجية
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن قائلا ان
القوات الروسية وانظمتها
الصاروخية داخل الاوكرانية مضيفة
اثناء عملها في منطقة العملية
العسكرية في اوكرانيا ليطلع على
عظمى ولن تسمح ابدا لنفسها
بالخسارة في اي مواجهة. مضيفا
زار وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويجو مقر مجموعة قوات بوستوك
بقيمة ثلاثة مليارات يورو. مضيفة
انهم لن يتراجع عن دعم اوكرانيا
يقولها المصريون اللي يتهور مع
نيت عور. بل تحذروا ولتعلموا ان
هولندا هي من تدفع الفاتورة
الاضخم ماليا وبشريا. وكما
اكد لافروف استعداد بلاده
للاستجابة لما سماها اي اقتراحات
الحروب لكن في اوكرانيا لا شيء
معلوم. وها هو وزير الخارجية
غير العادة وايلون ماسك يفاجئ
بكين. الكيان الاسرائيلي يسمح
الامريكي هنري كسنجر يصرح لقد
حان الوقت اوكرانيا لحلف الناتو.
لجميع سفراء الاوروبيين بالدخول
للمسجد الاقصى ويمنع سفير الاردن
روسيا تلعب بورقة الموت.
المفاوضات ستحدث وهكذا تنتهي
تسخن محركاتها وتتحضر لدخول
الحرب. بينما الصين تتراجع على
لن نتراجع عن دعم اوكرانيا ويجب
محاسبة موسكو. وواشنطن تستخدم
المليار دولار بشكل اضافي في
اطار المساعدات العسكرية
حيث اعلنت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
ان قاذفتي الاستراتيجيتين
يتواصل ولا ينقطع وهذه المرة من
الاتحاد الاوروبي اجمع. حيث
اسرائيل وكوريا الجنوبية كقفازات
ضد الروس في اوكرانيا والثعلب
اذا مللنا من هذه اللعبة بكل
بساطة سنضغط على الزر النووي
والسلام عليكم. هكذا قالها
قديروف والاتحاد الاوروبي يرد.
عضو جديد الى نادي الداعمين
لكييف. نعم. انه رئيس الوزراء
لاوكرانيا يتزايد من اجل تأمين
صمودها في وجه الهجمة الروسية كي
قرار تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا هو
قرار سيادي لكل بلد. وان دعمهم
الروسي سيرجي لافروف يعلن ان
التحدث مع الغرب امر لا طائل
ليعود سفراء اوروبا للتوسط له.
فهل ناجح وساطتهم وقمة خليجية
مفاجئة وقطر تطمئن العالم بشأن
الغاز.
الروسية?
وهولندا تدخل بسخاء على خط الدعم
الاوكراني. قاذفات روسية مرعبة